[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour ce
nouveau numéro 10 est une culture tout
de suite le sommaire de ce mardi 15
janvier une pincée de cinéma un peu de
vidéo et beaucoup de musique la recette
d'un voyage rêvé celui d'hippocampes où
le rappeur vous entraîne à travers le
monde à la merise de trappes des livres
des lectures des spectacles pour cette
troisième édition de la nuit de la
lecture saint quentin en yvelines ouvre
musées médiathèques et lieux culturels
70 chanteurs et huit musiciens pour un
anniversaire le saint quentin gospel
fête cette année ses 25 ans l'occasion
de revenir sur son histoire et les
festivités que le coeur prépare
hippocampe fouet l'ucad auriez vous
emmène en voyage les deux artistes font
le tour du monde en musique un spectacle
né de leur rencontre qu'ils finalisent
actuellement à la merise de trappes rap
hip hop et vidéo pour un conte musical
[Musique]
faites vos valises un voyage vous attend
le rappeur hippocampe vous entraîne dans
ses rêves 80 à travers le monde
vélo cazaux début de faire des
recherches ne serait ce que sur les
instruments de différents lieux sur les
têtes les étés formules rythmiques sur
l'harmonie sur des choses comme ça
voulait sortir un petit peu de deux
structures actuelles quoi de faire de
fer pouvoir frapper par exemple sur des
sur des rythmiques un peu particulière
sur des harmonies étrange des choses
comme ça quoi c'est un challenge une
oeuvre né d'une rencontre le batteur
lucas d'aurier lance l'idée il ya six
ans il peut comme fou les deux artistes
habitués des concerts veulent créer une
pièce qui mêle musique et vidéo
[Musique]
première idée c'était quoi c'était de
mélanger la musique du monde avec le hip
hop et après avoir listé un petit peu
tous les tous les pays où tous les
genres musicaux qu'on pouvait mélanger
on s'est dit avec tout ça on peut
raconter une histoire et avoir fait le
scénario de de la terre à la lune
l'odyssée d'ipo s'inspire aussi du monde
de la musique de film
une mise en scène épurée pour laisser
parler les partitions et vidéo est pour
quand vont vous entraîne avec
gourmandise dans ses aventures
[Musique]
vous pouvez aussi vous évader aux
clayes-sous-bois avec les clichés de
rhône entre autres chez le jeune
photographe expose près 2 79 issu d'un
voyage de plus d'un en birmanie bolivie
pérou ou encore madagascar amateurs
avertis ils aiment capturer les regards
de ceux qu'il a rencontrés lors de ce
périple
la plupart du temps c'est plutôt de
l'instantané parce que quand on demande
généralement le le petit cachet n'est
plus là l'instant n'est plus là mais
l'idée c'est que en fait sont des
portraits c'est aussi leur rend hommage
aujourd'hui sont des portraits de
personnes chez qui on a soit vécue
soissons des personnes qu'on a
rencontrés donc elles ont la plupart
tout vu les photos mais après coup sans
forcément que le rang 10 au départ que
je les prenaient en photo aux
clayes-sous-bois il ya aussi du cinéma
les chats me joue à cache-cache invente
des histoires sous l'oeil de monsieur
chat un court métrage à découvrir à
l'espace physique man ray en regardant
l'extrait avoir un animal de combat
celui-là mois
je vais plonger attention tout le monde
j'ai envie se marier vital en u15 et u16
qui s'égaillent dans la salle de bain
[Musique]
boum
la nuit de la culture c'est ce samedi 19
janvier la nuit de la lecture pardon
pour cette troisième édition
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines nous a concocté tout un
programme des spectacles et des lectures
bien sûr les médiathèques vous accueille
en journée et en soirée mais pas
seulement à la commanderie vous pourrez
voyager avec les itinéraires poétique et
son directeur est avec mon plateau
jacques fournier bonjourbonjour mélanie
gars de 20 heures à minuit poètes
comédiens et comédiennes investissent le
site
oui parce que on a eu envie de à la
commanderie dans cet espace que nous
faisons vivre avec des partenaires et
des collègues de la direction du
rayonnement culturel de saint quentin on
a eu envie de faire entendre des textes
mais pas uniquement de la poésie il y
aura des extraits de romans de très
certainement de pièces de théâtre je ne
sais pas donc chacun vient avec les
livres qu'ils ont envie de lire
ce sont des comédiens et des poètes et
des comédiennes que nous avons invité
nous avons choisi parmi les gens avec
lesquels nous travaillons aussi
habituellement et puis aussi des
nouvelles têtes puisqu'il y aura saïd
mohamed qui vient de recevoir un grand
prix de l'académie charles cros il y
aura claudine bories qui sera notre
invité d'honneur au printemps des poètes
donc voilà on a eu envie de mélanger un
petit peu tous ces gens là de 20h à
minuit et chacun aura un deux ou peut
être trois créneaux de lecture l'entrée
est libre les gens viennent quand ils
veulent ils rentrent ils sortent si ça
leur plaît ils peuvent rester sur le
plateau ils peuvent partir absolument
aucune contrainte
la particularité c'est que ces poètes
comédiennes et comédiens vont circuler
autour au travers d'une nouvelle
exposition
oui on sera au coeur à la on est on est
au coeur de l'exposition d'anne ramène
installé par par ma collègue de ophélie
ophélie petit des arts visuels
une oeuvre une exposition de
photographies noir et blanc grand format
sur le mouvement sur le corps il est
allé photographier des danseurs et de
danseuses sur saint quentin en yvelines
est au coeur de cette exposition nous
proposerons nous par contre quelque
chose peut-être d'un peu plus statique
puis ce qu'on propose comme thème une
lecture sur la lecture c'est à dire sur
les mots sur sur la bibliothèque
voilà cet instant on en est plus dans
l'immobilité donc je voulais jouer un
petit peu sur ce contraste là sachant
aussi que nous d'une certaine manière
nous allons
initiée le village du mot que nous
allons lancer avec les médiathèques de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines les 31 31 mars
à la commanderie nouvelles
manifestations pendant deux jours autour
du autour du mot seulement du mot on
voit là j'ai eu envie de faire un petit
kit avant-première quoi là dessus 1 la
nuit de la lecture j'imagine c'est un
moment aussi pour sensibiliser
sensibiliser à l'activité on lit
peut-être de montjean - alors il paraît
qu'on lit de moins en moins il ya de
moins en moins de ventes de livres ça
c'est sûr c'est pas obligatoirement à
cause d'internet et des tablettes c'est
parce que peut-être que le livre est
moins attrayant qu'il n'a été moi je
suis toujours attiré par les livres
c'est je vis dedans je vis au milieu de
tout cela avec mes collègues du
bibliothécaire de saint quentin en
yvelines
donc si fait que cette cette nuit la
lecture que nous organisons sur deux
lieux
c'est aussi une occasion peut-être de
ramener un certain lectorat vers les
livres mais je sais que les
bibliothèques font aussi un gros travail
tout au long de l'année là dessus et
doux avec les itinéraires politique par
la rencontre avec des poètes par les
spectacles et les débats les
manifestations que nous organisons nous
incitons les gens à aller vers le livre
aussi et pas seulement le livre de
poésie elle vaut mieux mettre le public
va pouvoir voyager découvrir l'amérique
est ce que ce thème là est aussi
transposé avec les itinéraires à la
commanderie temps de la lecture mais ce
sera vraiment la lecture après il y aura
peut-être des textes d'auteurs
américains
oui ils ont choisi sur les soirs le mime
est donc une soirée de 19 heures à 23
heures de déambulation
autour des amériques donc avec
différents lecteurs mais au départ il ya
18 heures il ya une des contes pour les
enfants pour pouvoir les clichés plus
vite c'est bien
après donc les parents pourront
déambuler mais aussi des enfants bien
entendu jusque 23h
non non on n'a pas en europe a repris ce
thème des amériques on l'a déjà abordé
avec les itinéraires politique par une
conférence l'an dernier au théâtre de
saint quentin
là non je me suis pas du tout attachés à
ça ça s'inscrit dans le cadre de la fête
du compte puisque ces lancements mais
vous en reparlerai plus tard et donc le
nom le choix était vraiment très
différent
la démarche n'est pas du tout la même là
on a ce lien aussi 7
on va dire cette antinomie avec
l'exposition de dan ramène sur le
mouvement mais voilà c'est des choix
petit clin d'oeil qu'on se fait de temps
en temps aussi injustement comment on
fait son choix parce qu'il ya des
ouvrages il en sort tous les ans un très
grand nombre depuis des années comment
on a choisi le thème de la lecture c'est
quand même très très vaste alors le
thème de la lecture moi je suis je suis
attiré par les bibliothèques
je suis attiré par les eaux si je
découvre parfois dans des coupes parfois
au détour d'une page d'une lecture un
passage sur un livre sur un mot sur une
phrase sur une bibliothèque ou sur une
librairie
là j'ai lu récemment un polar coréen qui
se passe pendant la guerre 4 39 45 dans
un camp de prisonniers coréen camp
japonais de prisonniers coréen et le
jeune héros qui doit enquêter sur un
meurtre abominable
on apprend qu'il est le fils d'un
libraires de livres d'occasion et il
raconte des passages où il parle de du
moment où il découvre la littérature
principalement la littérature européenne
et il refuse de vendre le livre qu'il a
entre les mains que réclame le client
voilà il le cache et donc ses passages
la moelle intéresse énormément
et puis je crois que les poètes les
comédiens sont attirés par le livre la
lecture sinon ils nous feraient pas ces
métiers là où ces activités là il
n'aurait pas ses passions et donc je
leur ai dit quand je veux j'aurais
proposé ce thème je rédige je suis sûr
que vous avez quelque part un livre un
texte un recueil un extrait de texte qui
parle de la lecture qui parle d'une
bibliothèque on peut parler la
bibliothèque de umberto eco dans le nom
de la rose la bibliothèque de borghèse
dans nombre de ces livres on peut parler
d'eux
ii ya un livre qui vient de sortir ou un
écrivain son nom m'échappe complètement
évoque ses bibliothèques il a dû laisser
derrière lui à force de déménager je
vois là on a sept souvent l'histoire du
livre dans le livre c'est une mise en
abyme et cette mise en abyme m'intéresse
beaucoup à vous le disiez l'entrée est
libre
oui est ce qu'il ya une question de
limite de place non non parce que on
sait bien que les gens vont pas venir à
350 400 dans cette salle on va être
obligé de limiter on a une jauge
inévitablement on ne peut pas dire aux
gens vous venez de telle heure à telle
heure l'entrée est libre c'est de 20h à
minuit à minuit on s'arrête on faire une
flamme et voilà il s'agira aussi de
découvrir l'exposition de dan ramène en
écoutant les textes sur à des chaises
mais y aura possibilité aussi de se
déplacer merci à jacques fournier alors
un petit mot par rapport à la fête du
conte que dont vous parliez en effet la
nuit de la lecture feu lance cette fête
du conte et ses marylène agapit
cheminots qui développera le programme
avec son invité dans l'édition du 7 8
loisirs du jeudi 17 janvier pour ce qui
est de la troisième née de la lecture
les rendez-vous débute par une lecture
spectacle la compagnie des dramaticules
suspend le temps à la médiathèque le
nautilus le conteur stéphane des feux et
les élèves d'une classe de l'école de la
grande île vous propose là l'histoire de
nasreddine sur la banquise et pour ne
rien rater de ce rendez-vous direction
comme toujours le site kiosque prince
qui point fr on va continuer de parler
poésie depuis neuf ans pau a été
photographe plaisir wa s'associent pour
créer une exposition pour l'eau dans
tous ses états les textes accompagnés
les clichés à la médiathèque du château
jusqu'au 31 janvier
marylène iapichino et patrick jacques de
dixmude quand la photographie amène à la
poésie l'association un temps poète
s'associe à ces des photographes de
plaisir pour une exposition les
photographes proposent leurs clichés sur
une thématique et les poètes sont
inspire pour leur verre c'est toujours
la grande surprise en fait dans les yeux
des photographes de voir comment leurs
photos a pu être interprétée et parfois
la même photo par plusieurs poètes dans
plusieurs regards sur leur premier
regard final cette année photos et
poèmes sont sur le thème de l'eau dans
tous ses états libre à tout interprète
sinon je chante pour vous aux femmes
comme l'oiseau des bois chantant le jour
naissant
je chante la joie qui rayonne en vous
c'est des femmes dans l'eau un rapport
proche de la fin et l'eau parce que la
femme est porteuse de ville aussi
l'épandage de vie et donc je trouvais
que là il y avait vraiment une
une similitude un rapport direct les
deux associations plaisir oise
collaborent pour cette exposition depuis
neuf ans elle alimente chacune la
créativité de l'autre et ne sont pas en
nombre d'idées souvent ils nous ont dit
mais sans que l'on n'ait pu encore le
maître le mettre en oeuvre
c'est qu' il faudrait pouvoir aussi
faire le chemin inverse c'est à dire
qu'on leur propose des textes et que eux
trop la photo 80 clichés accompagnés de
leurs mots sont exposés à la médiathèque
du château de plaisir jusqu'à la fin du
mois plus de 60 ans avant après sa
première publication fahrenheit 451 le
roman de ray bradbury est toujours
d'actualité cette société futur où les
livres sont interdits où les pompiers
ont pour mission de les brûler le
classique de la littérature de science
fiction a inspiré la compagnie les
inventeurs les arpenteurs de
l'invincible de l'invisible c'est un
souvenir scolaire qui a inspiré le
metteur en scène c'est un bouquin que
qui traînait sur les rayons du collège
delà du cdi du collège
il y avait un monsieur qui crachait du
feu ce titre était un peu étonnant et
puis je pensais en bouquin très actuel
qui parle de la littérature de la place
de la littérature dans notre société la
place de l'émotion de la sensation dans
la société des écrans comment est ce
qu'on vit dans une société d écran sans
se couper de l'autre il n'ya pas que les
livres il ya aussi la musique en 1994
une annonce paraissait dans la presse
locale une demande pour les amateurs de
gospel 25 ans plus tard le saint quentin
gospel est toujours là et pour son
anniversaire des concerts de fait aux
happy birthday sont programmées à la
ferme de bel ébat une actualité dont on
a parlé avec nous
invitée chantal bruno et patrick m
bonjour à tous les deux alors vous êtes
présidente et vice-président du
saint-quentin gospel du coeur de concert
le 19 et 20 janvier mais chantal bruno
tout est prêt presque c'est la dernière
ligne droite tout le monde a répété les
musiciens le chef de choeur les
choristes et donc voilà tout va bien se
passer je pense pour les deux concerts
patrick maître en 25 ans plus de 200
morceaux rejoint le répertoire
qu'est ce qu'on va pouvoir écouter ce
week-end eh bien écoutez si vous révéler
ah oui voilà on va essayer de garder une
petite surprise quand même mais nous
avons essayé de dison de de livrer notre
répertoire actuel celui de la de la
saison en cours mais en plus il ya des
petites choses qui reviennent disons de
l'ancien répertoire qu'on a mixé dans
quelques medleys donc tout ça va faire
quelque chose comme je sais pas si on
doit le dire encore aujourd'hui enfin
peuple quelque chose comme 25 cents
c'est énorme et c'est bon est-ce que
vous ne vous d'interpréter que des
titres de gospel où vous allez chercher
peut-être des titres actuels que vous
transformez avec vos voix c'est
compliqué si palm ans principalement ce
sont des titres de gospel parfois il
arrive qu'on chante des chansons plus du
aperture pop comme par exemple chocat
losc on a chanté sur une deux saisons
mais généralement c'est vraiment du
gospel 4 quoi faire alors vous le disiez
vous répéter régulièrement c'est une
fois par semaine et mon collègue patrick
jacques de dixmude s'est glissé parmi
vous on écoute un extrait
[Musique]
non
ah ah
hélas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
patrick mais j'imagine que ses concerts
une saveur un peu particulière c'est pas
le concert vous en faites 5,6 par an
c'est ça j'imagine que c'est pas les
cinq six concerts habituels celui là est
important pour pour nous d'autant que
nous avons là la visite de quelques fins
qu on dit quelques sans doute une petite
vingtaine de choristes d'anciens
choristes qui viendront cette occasion
là pour les 25 ans et c'est un événement
enfin c'est l'événement de la saison
pour nous vu justement depuis 25 ans
l'amour du gospel ne se dément pas on le
voit entre 60 et 80 chanteurs réunit
chaque année les gens viennent
spontanément ou oui nous avons beaucoup
de candidatures spontanées
on peut on your comment dire on ne
refuse aussi beaucoup parce que diriger
un coeur de 70 choristes c'est déjà
compliqué alors 90 ou 100 je vous laisse
alors qu'est ce qui fait la force du
gospel vous même qu'est ce qui vous
plaît pour chanter depuis ce temps là
l'unité c'est très joyeux l'émotion et
c'est l'émotion c'est le partage c'est
vraiment les valeurs du gospel
et puis l'énergie qu'on y trouve parce
que je pense que les gens qui viennent
nous voir
ir ils ressortent avec avec le sourire
ils sont heureux ils sont mais galvanisé
voilà et beaucoup d'entre nous beaucoup
d'entre nous disent oui mais quand est
ce qu'on peut et est-ce qu'on peut venir
chanter avec vous etc
et c'est vraiment enfin je suis pas je
pense que c'est aussi le but recherché
quoi c'est de vraiment transmettre cette
culture gospel
mais malgré tout le gospel demande
beaucoup de technique j'aime concert
qu'avait fait j'ai testé il ya quelques
années il ya de l'échauffement sachant
pas comme ça a quand même mauvaise elle
non il faut il faut de l'énergie mais
c'est quelque chose qui se gagne
on a un chef de choeur aussi qui nous
qui nous porte
il faut savoir que notre chef de choeur
qui a qui a créé la chorale au départ
ils risquent barbier abba énormément
donné à cette chorale et lui a permis
d'atteindre un niveau qui est un niveau
que nous estimons très très bon pour
nous on est on est très fiers de ce
travail là qu'il a fait pendant des
années avec nous et là depuis deux ans
nous avons simon luro qui a repris cette
le flambeau un jeune chef de choeur les
tout jeunes ils allègent du cac j'ai
tendance à court facile qui l'a amené de
marc sa jeunesse le tête sur sa disant
sa façon de travailler
les lélés déchaussement vocaux etc
donc voilà oui c'est pas la même c'est
pas la même chose évidemment on a un un
chef de choeur qu'il ya 25 ans qu'il ya
une optimiste mais une fougue assez
communicative et d'ailleurs ça se voit
sur scène on va voir ce que ça va ce que
ça va donner pour l'épauler pour les 25
ans et puis vous allez voir que ça c'est
des ménages et donc on a la même énergie
et la même joie de chanter
voilà on est de 25 ans qui est plutôt
bien y'en a qu'on fait 25 ans dans les
clubs mais la voix ne fatigue pas on
arrive à conjuguer que son emploi du
temps
c'est parfois difficile ça dépend des
des métiers que l'on n'exerce mais je
pense que les gens sont tellement
contents de se retrouver dans cette
chorale c'est comme une deuxième famille
pour nous voilà on a créé des liens et
tisser des liens tout au long des années
voilà c'est justement
avoir un souvenir de vos années au coeur
moi le premier souvenir c'est le premier
concert je crois que chacun sait ce qui
marque le plus en plus j'avais eu la
chance de participer à un concert dans
une église
et ça il dit que la chanson notation
particulière l'église parce que ça porte
un 10 ont une dimension différente quoi
juste pour revenir par la suite il est
tout à l'heure il faut savoir que dans
les dents les les choristes qui forment
cette chorale est bien on en a une
vingtaine qui sont qui sont venus dans
les dix premières années celles qui sont
toujours là vous avez un noyau dur par
contre il y en a depuis cinq ans il a
une trentaine de nouveaux donc ça bouge
aussi beaucoup car vous je voudrais
juste dire un mot sur eric barbier vous
l'avait nommé à plusieurs reprises donc
en 2017 s'il cède sa place à simon
l'euro est-ce qu'il est toujours là non
il n'est plus là il y avait deux parties
en province mais il reviendra ce
week-end pour nous voir sur scène et
fêter cet anniversaire avec nous et
justement vous avez pu échanger avec lui
de l'évolution de ce vus en échange
régulièrement avec les ouïes de venir je
voudrais vous demander où va conclure
les deux matches parce que c'était les
10 ans de saint quentin gospel ça s'est
passé au palais des congrès à versailles
il y avait une première partie avec un
intervenant gospel très connu à paris et
puis nous avons chanté aussi après et
c'était vraiment un souvenir très très
fort quand on était très nombreux sur
sept et c'était vraiment bien un autre
site et quand on est allé à en suède
pour les bulls si mal de besoin de
voyager en plus là parfois hélas c'était
très bref est-ce que d'autres rendez
vous sont à prévoir cette année il n'y a
pas que cet anniversaire j'imagine alors
il ya un rendez-vous mois d'avril au
théâtre de chaville c'est un concert
pour la map
une association contre les mines
antipersonnel et ensuite je pense qu'il
y aura la fête de la musique
voilà pour cette année on est en
pourparlers avec d'autres concerts
je sais pas si saint germain on pourra
le refaire ce que savait à voir si c'est
en tout cas à ne pas rater les 19 et 20
janvier à la firme devait les bas merci
à vous d'être bientôt pour souffler les
25 bougies du saint-quentin gospel avec
les choristes de concert et les dates
s'affiche en bas de l'écran déclic
théâtre championnat de france
d'improvisation mozart l'opéra rock
laurie perry est aujourd'hui sur scène
pour son one man show des chansons
écrites et composées pour la plupart sur
le piano de sa fille regardez ce que je
souhaite c'est que je crois que j'ai
réussi à enfin je sais personnages
auxquels on quand on excuse tout parce
qu'on semble caler complètement fragile
et qu'effectivement la pas les codes de
ce qui se dit et de ce qui ne se dit pas
donc pas du tout ce qui lui passe
exactement
et elle raconte des trucs dont on se
serait bien passé et effectivement voilà
on les pardonne et ça me permets moi de
raconter ce que afro parcours de mère
célibataire avec non mais c'est
évidemment grandement inspiré parce que
je crois que je peux pas écrire des
trucs qui me qui me parlent pas ou qui
me correspond pas donc oui il ya des
situations avec mon enfant qui mois mais
ses conclusions la genre notamment quand
je parle de la maternelle et de et de
mes grandes problématiques matinale de
ne pas pouvoir me réveiller ça c'est
complètement vrai parti et ça fait
c'est le nombre de ces droits
[Musique]
c'est le nom de centimètres et ça ne
fait pas très mal qu'une bonne vraie
pour voir revoir l'intégralité de cet
entretien direction le site internet de
tv 78 on passe maintenant à notre page
agenda
un rendez-vous bouleversant au théâtre
montansier de versailles vous n'aurez
pas ma haine d'antoine leiris et mis en
scène par benjamin guihard un post
facebook
un livre est aujourd'hui une pièce
interprétée par raphaël personnaz
extrait je dois rejoindre mais ville qui
se réveille de sa schiste
il va prendre son goûter
comme tous les jours
[Musique]
et je vais jouer avec lui comme tous les
jours et toute sa vie ce petit garçon
vous fera l'affront d'être heureux et
libres
carreman vous n'aurez pas ça non plus
une nouveauté chez art gravure saint
quentin en yvelines à l'atelier lent sur
une nouvelle action la carte blanche la
première l et pour michel urbany peintre
et graveur
l'exposition est à découvrir jusqu'au 17
février les rencontres pour easy ouverte
continue à versailles pour ce nouveau
rendez vous disiez qu'un invite bruno
douce et à la bibliothèque centrale
toujours à versailles est un festival de
musique classique christine est généraux
et mon fred steels interpréteront
schumann debussy et chopin
leur concert sera précédé d'un récital
jeunes talents classique
une initiative originale au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines pour les
rencontres une cité le site propose de
rang de récolter recettes de famille et
de fait ou de tous les jours et vous
avez jusqu'au 25 janvier pour participer
et déposez votre propre recette et du
côté du prisme on se la joue cabaret la
salle élan courtoise invite tous les
amoureux de vin était française pour un
karaoké
sandrine cost vous accompagnera une
soirée programmée en préambule du
spectacle sosie qui sera lui le jouet le
22 janvier prochain
c'est la fin de cette étude culture
merci de nous avoir suivi on se retrouve
mardi prochain pour un nouveau numéro
[Musique]